hello and welcome to inside Germany my
guest today is the first ever female
French horn player to have made it into
the revered Berlin Philharmonic
Orchestra Sarah Willis is British and
she's actually lived in Berlin since
1991 when she joined another Orchestra
here the stat capella that's this state
opera companies Orchestra under the
battle of maestro daniel barenboim
welcome to the show um let's start with
that edge you have played under the
battles of two of the greatest
conductors of our time who are both here
in Berlin that Daniel Barenboim as I
mentioned answer Simon Rattle so how do
they how do they compare what are they
like well that's a difficult question to
say how they compare because the best
thing about classical music about any
sort of music is that that no two people
are the same no two pieces are the same
and and maestro barenboim and Sir Simon
are so totally different musicians
they're both utter geniuses and I've
learned so much from both of them that
they're practically incomparable I am
very grateful to my strobe our brown boy
because that was my first job in the
starts capella it was a difficult time
for me in Berlin it was just after the
wall had come down I was the first
Westerner to join the orchestra nobody
spoke English so he would always do the
rehearsals in his best German but he
would speak English to me so I was
grateful for that that's what in the
rehearsals he would do everything in
seven and then yeah Josh do you the only
English person I was the first Westerner
the only English person and I imagined
at the beginning they must have thought
I'd come from Mars because there was
this little English girl with a French
horn which was also not terribly usual
in those days to have a girl playing the
French horn and I had to learn German
pretty quickly but Barham was fantastic
and we did I learned so many fantastic
operas with him and the whole Ring cycle
of Wagner and and and then he my
favorite moments were when he would play
Beethoven at the piano and conduct from
the piano and they're moving on to Simon
it's been the last ten years with him
has been a musical roller coaster it's
fantastic we've been learning so many
new pieces he
bring lots of new stuff to the Berlin
Philharmonic lots of crazy stuff and he
rehearses in English maybe actually now
he rehearses and Joe does it yes is
German is so much better
um his best jokes are still in English
though ok ok now I mentioned you're the
first female horn player you're actually
the first female member of the brass
section of the Berlin Philharmonic why
do you think this is wise
well brass playing was a bit of a man's
world of originally and and when I was
asked what I wanted to play I needed a
second instrument in London if you want
to study at one of the music colleges
you need two instruments and and I play
the piano quite well so I thought I'd
study a second instrument and I said
what what could I study and they said
how about the flute or the or the
clarinet and or oboe nothing against
those instruments but they just weren't
really my thing and the teacher said
well we have a French horn but actually
only boys play the French horn and I
thought I want to try that I wanted to
be something a little bit different so I
tried the French horn and I was really
one of the only girls learning in those
days but things have changed so much and
if you look at all the conservatories
around the world it's full of fantastic
young female brass players so I I'm the
first girl in the Berlin Film Ross
section but I'm certainly not the last
okay now um you've bought your French
home with you and how wonder if you'd
pick it up and show us now because I
know the way you hold it you have your
hand in the Bell I do but that's not
just about that's not the reason that
the hand is in the Bell or is it um when
we do a lot of education projects and we
go to the kindergarten in the schools
and that's actually one of the first
questions why do you put your hand up
the Bell so well done I'm a little child
bombed um well firstly of course if we
didn't put our hand in the bell it would
be like this
and in the old days the horn was a
hunting instrument and they would have
to sit on that on the horses or whatever
they were hunting on and play it like
this so they would hold it up like that
and they'd have to hold it still because
I guess on their horses that I can't
imagine playing the horn on a horse so
but to make the sound a bit better that
sounds quite raw if you
listen it that's okay yeah but if you
put your hand in it and cup it a little
bit I hope this is gonna sound better
it's just a little pure sound
the other reason is that in the old days
we didn't have all these tubing bits and
we didn't have the valves we just could
jet the harmonic series which was just a
certain number of notes in the same key
and they realized that they could start
changing the notes with the hand so you
could go now we can go in the old days
they used to do it with the hand so that
was a good question the other question
the kids always want to know is what are
you always blowing out of the horn is
that spit and I'd like to say on the
record it's not spit well not only
anyway it's condensed water cuz you blow
you blow cold air a hot air down cold
tubing and then a bit of condensed water
comes out I just wanted to show now
another use a French horn picture you
sent to us of this yeah is he a little
monkey he's little monkey he's a little
little baby monkey at the Berlin Zoo um
and when when my photographer friend
Monica she does most incredible photos
and I said sure we can't use that one
I've got so many wrinkles you said we'll
look at the monkeys got more than you
okay well anyway we know that the the
bell of the horn changes the sound of
the instrument we also know it's a great
place for small animals to sit in and
it's not just small animals that like
the bells of French horns
my guest is Sara with us here on inside
Germany what do you think they make of
that well the when when I had apples in
my horn
they were quite interested in the apples
but when I suggested I play for them the
the keepers at the zoo actually made me
leave the enclosure because as you saw
they have a little baby there and those
are the ladies those are the four ladies
and they're very protective of this baby
and they were afraid that my horn player
might sound like a an enemy elephant and
so they weren't quite sure how they'd
react so they made me play from outside
but they all came up and they they
trumpeted back at me yeah yeah what we
saw yeah
now I said at the beginning of this show
you're British and you have a British
accent but you weren't actually born in
Britain were you and I believe you hold
two passports is right I've got a
passport and a passport because I was
born in America I've got it we've got a
map I think of where you were born I'm
glad you have I don't really remember it
at all a Festa in Maryland indeed yeah
so you have a passport in the past yes
my father was a naturalized American he
was actually born in Australia it's very
complicated but when I was born he was
in an American citizen my mum's British
so I was lucky to have two possible and
was it a musical family my grandmother
my father's side was a concert pianist
but she lived in Australia so we didn't
really know her that well my father was
a foreign correspondent and my mother is
a ballet critic so there's a bit of
music in there somewhere but we we just
we loved to perform as kids we were
always making up concerts and plays and
all sorts of things so but the love of
performing was always there yeah and you
settled eventually in London when you
were 13 I think and is that where you
really sort of took on the music that's
the eriously that's when it started I
remember that there was a moment in
Massa we lived in Moscow before that dad
was posted in Moscow were there for five
years and I remember visiting the
Bolshoi Theatre quite a lot because of
my mother's ballet connections and we
went to the Moscow Conservatory and
heard sviatoslav richter playing the
Tchaikovsky Piano Concerto and I was so
blown away by this I swore to myself
that that's what I wanted to do and I
wanted to play that concerto I've played
it on the horn in the orchestra I
haven't managed on the piano yet
kind of tricky another picture oh thank
you very much hey did your the front
cover of a French magazine yes I am very
honored to have that lid gone don't Duke
or well yes that was me at age fourteen
I'd been sent outside to practice while
we were on holiday in Shropshire because
I was making such a racket okay now I I
actually did show that pitch because I
wanted to show something else because
you are in the latest edition of um
Vogue magazine no less at the German
Vogue magazine huge mama show this up to
the camera a huge honor when when are
the the the company that makes our horns
music Alexander when they saw that photo
they said oh it's such a wonderful photo
and I thought oh how nice I said the
horn looks so great
hey come on you made it in today I know
it's a really big honor we still can't
quite believe it there you studied at
the Guildhall School of Music and Drama
where I also studied actually and you
you were on a performance course did you
um have a back-up plan if it didn't work
out as a performer I had absolutely no
backup plan whatsoever do you remember
at school when we had to go to these
careers lessons did you have career
lesson we had somebody coming in at
school telling us about what it's like
to be a policeman or a bus driver or a
scientist I never went I went to
practice and I got in terrible trouble
for this they said what are you gonna do
later if you can't be a horn player and
I said but I'm going to be a horn player
and for me there was absolutely no doubt
but once I got to college to music
college I was suddenly out of my comfort
zone and I'd always been the best little
horn player in my area I know that one
yeah I was the best singer
yeah and then you get earlier there were
lots of them and there's so many around
you and my confidence just went down and
I really that's when I thought oh I
don't have a back-up plan um but and
then but then you came to Berlin before
you after college what and and why did
you come to Berlin because that was you
hadn't actually got the job in this yeah
yet I'm going on a little Chamber
Orchestra tour while that war was still
there and we played at the Hebel tiata
the Hubble Theatre we played a little
opera by hence ER and one night
members of the Berlin Philharmonic had
come to the performance and
I've been so blown away by the
performance that they invited us to the
rehearsal the next day in the Philemon
II so we all got up really early went to
the Philemon ii and sat there and this
was while i was in my third year of
music college and I heard this orchestra
play live for the first time and I just
thought that is the sound I've been
looking for I have to be as close to
this Orchestra as I possibly can and in
the break we were so brave we went
backstage and found some of the horn
players one of which was Fergus
MacWilliam who is now my colleague the
second horn player of the Berlin Phil
and and I heard these was like an
out-of-body experience I heard myself
saying could I come and study with you
and the other horn player was digging me
in the ribs sort of saying don't be so
cheeky but for some reason it was just
the right thing to do and I went and had
some lessons with him got a scholarship
in in London a Countess of Munster
scholarship that paid for me to go over
and eventually there was the job free
and the Staatsoper and Fergus said go
for it yeah and you said earlier that
you you were the first Westerners in the
starts capella and you were here just
after the wall came down I wonder I mean
it's changed immensely in the last 20
years hasn't Harry how do you feel it's
changed it's it's changed and that that
well there's there's we called bullsh
death and building sites all over Berlin
that they've been there for 20 years
they just changed places and um when I
first was here and it was just literally
the week the wall was coming down that
was that was I was here in Berlin and I
I'd gone home two days earlier but I've
missed the whole thing and I came back a
few weeks later I just thought what a
fantastic what a cool place
Berlin is and that hasn't changed for me
literally in 20 years I still find
Berlin an incredibly vibrant exciting
city as I'm sure everybody says on your
program who lives here it's it's just a
fantastic place to be especially for
artists especially for the Arts you were
it you feel proud to be an artist here
and in other countries artists tend to
be sometimes people that have to work
very hard to scrape a living together
and and here you're treated very very
well and I've always appreciated that in
Berlin it's just it's got so many hidden
depths it is indeed mind you you say
that about being appreciated an artist
in it this country subsidized the arts
more than any other per capita in the
world
I was left free Sara Lee a good thing
should artists struggle a bit sometimes
well I struggled when I was at college I
think most of us did it music college
you know trying to do this gig to pay
your rent and all the rest of it and
when you're in London you can't afford
to live in town unless you're very rich
or have a very good job so you know all
this traveling time you spend getting in
and out of town that you don't have that
here it was a bit of a struggle in
London as a musician in Berlin it hasn't
been but you're right as you say it's
heavily subsidized and maybe that's
because they're very proud of their
cultural heritage and I'm not saying
that England isn't it's just they don't
put up the money for it like the German
I mean it's not extraordinary it really
is we all know we just reel off
classical music composers are without it
apart from the arts though I mean you
say you love Berlin so much and and you
love the art scene here but at just
normal life what's special about the
little sure like normal life I love to
be able to get to work within ten
minutes
Berlin still has this feeling of being a
small a small town although it's it's
growing and growing but it's easy to get
places the the transport system works
not sure about the airports but that's
another subject we live in it's a joke
isn't it around the world we won't
mention sure no felt Airport so there's
the that's this whole infrastructure
thing just tends to work it has had its
challenges Ivan I'm sure every foreigner
here in Berlin or in Germany has known
what it's like to stand at the post or
the bank and not be able to speak proper
German and be barked at by people that
are not really willing to understand it
is quite lonely the first couple of
years before you get enough of a daily
notion out so the the Berlin accents to
be able to talk back to Berlin ash
snouts we should that's not just the
it's not just the accent it's there
they're very sort of in-your-face they
are an attitude if you come from England
where everybody is so polite and oh
don't oh oh and oh do you mind if it's
quite a shock to have someone get a door
you know if it's quite it's quite a
shock but they don't mean it nicely you
have to
understand it no they don't and I found
at my time at the start supper being
with all these East Germans it was it
was wonderful it was great and going out
to their little Duchess on the weekend
they all had wonderful garden jobs and
country houses and and um that's they
became my family and my Alan ooh you
you've stayed everything you've stayed
ever since now well we've seen Sarah at
the zoo now we join her in some of her
other favorite haunts here in Berlin
we are at the cafe I'm noisy the cafe at
the new lake it's called here in Berlin
and it's a beautiful place right in the
middle of the city
it's like a small oasis for me because
lots of friends live near here and you
can just call them up and say here let's
have a quick drink here at the cafe I'm
noisy it's beautiful it's peaceful and
it's really accessible which is
something very special about Berlin
this is a much better way to do things
brilliant eeeh garden you can compare
with Central Park in New York or Hyde
Park in London it's a fabulous place and
for me it's my way to work I ride my
bike through the tea garden in all sorts
of weather I've been here through snow
through sleet through rain through
beautiful Sun and it changes every day
it looks a little bit different and
there lots of hidden Lakes and lots of
hidden paths and it's just so well taken
care of it's a real it's once again an
oasis in the middle of the city
the Zegers Euler victory column here in
Berlin is a very important landmark for
me I have never walked up to the top I'm
ashamed to say and I'm hoping we're just
about to change that
long way up
it's actually quite a joke at the
beginning and now we're not even halfway
yeah I'm exhausted
Wow
it's my very first time up here in the
zico's Euler and I slept my horn all the
way up here which is no mean feat I
think that's my sport for the day it's
an absolutely amazing view and I don't
understand why I've been in Berlin for
such a long time and I've never been up
here before
look there's the Silla mony in the
background my home so the tea garden is
not only a beautiful place for nature
it's also very musical because as you
can see here we have a monument to the
three most famous composers at least for
me they are Beethoven Mozart and hiden
and it's an absolutely beautiful
monument and it's quite inspiring when
you ride pass out every day
now when she's not paying solos in the
park or with the Burton Philemon ago
kustra Sarah Willis has recorded her own
solo CDs and if you'd like to win a
signed copy of one write to us the
address is in sight at DW de and just
mentioned you're interested include your
postal address you could be our lucky
winner Sarah and and this this CD down
wait now this CD
this one is classical music that's right
it's a trio typical horn pieces Brahms
and Mozart the other one is a little bit
of a popular tunes from all over the
world it's called four corners and my
three colleagues at the Berlin
Philharmonic and I got together and got
all sorts of a rapier friends to arrange
different pieces like su Lucia from
parrot Paris waltzing matilda from
australia and they're all alone sleeps
two lion sleeps tonight and we don't
only play on that one honey lady gaga oh
not yet that should that'll be our next
one I must get in touch with to see if
she heard somebody playing a lady gaga
number on the accordion oh I'm on the
radio last night but I'm sure my
colleagues would love it if I started
dressing up in her costumes mm-hmm now
you you did say um earlier that you you
you moved around a lot as a child now
you move around a lot as an orchestral
musician as well I mean this who sent us
you have found them all the ones yes
that was in the desert in Doha and that
was yeah I just like animals and I saw
the camel I have my horn and my sister
said get on that camel I look a little
bit worried because the camera was just
about to sit down and I was afraid I was
gonna drop my horn
and and do you like the travel do you
liked it you know and how do orience is
different different in different parts I
love traveling if you if you don't then
you can't be in the Berlin Philharmonic
because we're really on the road all the
time we're real ambassadors and we're we
have a lot of touring and and then when
we're not touring and we're playing in
Berlin and we have free time then we go
off on small chamber music tours I've
just got back from a week in Argentina
met all sorts of wonderful Argentinian
horn players it is very tiring but I've
has been a global person I think because
of what my dad did and we lived in
several countries and we're always going
off on holidays I love it I love
traveling I love meeting people from
different different countries and the
audiences they do vary from place to
place for example in Japan they'll sit
totally quietly and you'll think oh they
don't like it because they'll clap very
politely but at the end of the concert
then they'll go really crazy we did a
concert in Beijing where it was so
smoggy inside the concert hall you could
hardly see the conductor but what you
could hear with lots of rustling because
people had brought their bags and
plastic bags and things to eat so smog
inside the gosh yeah another picture now
I want to talk about this because you do
do a lot of work which are we saw there
in the earlier report you do work with
children and tell us about that was a
very special moment we we have a big
education program at the Berlin
Philharmonic and I don't have children
myself so I doubly enjoy going and
working with the children and to see
their eyes when they discover an
instrument for the first time of course
when they see the [ __ ] and that's
always an impressive they love the
percussion the most because they can
make the most noise and the brass
instruments they love because they're
beautiful but this little girl here she
was more interested in my garden hose
and we have one we just happen to have
you just half an hour earlier strict now
when the kids when I mean I told you
that they asked why'd you put your hand
up and is that spit that comes out the
other thing they ask is how long would a
horn be if you if you unraveled it
because yeah there's a lot of tubing if
you're unraveled all the tubing it would
be about 20 feet but um as it is I tell
them it's very very long and to explain
how much air you need I put a shot hose
you can hold that this is about three
feet think I was going to be doing this
this is it holy a home so there you go
you can hold up really high and the kids
get quite a shock because you can
actually get a note out of this
or you could play I can't get all the
notes because that's what you learned
earlier but that helps them understand
how much air you need to get a noise
after the horn and this little girl she
fell in love with the garden hose she
didn't want to play my horn she wanted
the garden hose and could she get it no
time she could see it's all to do with
it it's all to do with the lips all you
have to do and everyone has to do this
at home now is just vibrate the lips as
if there was something on your lips that
you want to get rid of him okay oh God
very good you could get a note out of
the garden Rose a woman here we go here
we go
not bad I knew guys I'd rather like
those elephants I was just gonna say
those elephants might adopt you into
their tribe take this just a little
further
here are four grown-up people all
members of the Berlin for body so I'm
not the only idiot no I played have it
but that was our open day when we were
performing for a lot of children can you
actually sort of play it between the
four of you because obviously old
profession yeah you get the chin go
Leopold Mozart Harmon wrote a piece for
a garden hose and string orchestra so
yes you can if you have to have them all
the same length to get the same the same
it's very complicated anyone who wants
to know can can come back for another
but I have to say just like my gardener
yes Wow
but the funny thing is is when you go to
we do a lot of work in kindergartens
which are a little bit underprivileged
that don't have any relationship to
classical music - like in Kreuzberg or
an embedding sunshine scenario area of
Berlin and and I just imagine what it's
like when these kids go home to their
maybe their Turkish parents or and who
have never heard anything from classical
music say mommy I played on a garden
hose today they must think well there's
Berlin Philharmonic what is all that
about
there's one
and you talk about that also the Berlin
Philharmonic I mean there's lots of
things go on there I want to ask you
you're in the forefront of new
technology promoting classical music and
you're involved in what is said to be
the biggest classical music event ever
the YouTube Orchestra YouTube Symphony
Orchestra mean 30 million clicks or did
they actually watch at the time YouTube
said that 33 million tuned in live to
this to this event it was in Sydney and
the thing is you you see what the power
is of the Internet this was pushed very
cleverly on YouTube and Google everybody
had heard about the YouTube Symphony
Orchestra going on and and I think
people were just so I don't know whether
33 million people watched the whole
concert but they certainly had 33
million clicks so part out the Rolling
Stones and u2 and all the rest of you 33
million I'll give them some garden hoses
you know and the Philharmonic itself has
a big online presence too with the
digital concert hall that's different
that's different that's um that was a
the idea of actually one of the members
of our Orchestra Olaf Manning who
suddenly was you said he was jogging one
day and he came back and said to his
wife we have to go onto the Internet
because we used to make a lot of CDs and
and those days are really more or less
over nobody's really making buying CDs e
days but they're downloading all sorts
of things and and and Olaf said well why
don't we put all our concerts live on
the on the Internet and everyone's like
okay well let's give it a go and he
managed to get the sponsorship of
Deutsche Bank and we set up a studio
that is just for producing our concerts
we have it's a bit a little bit like Big
Brother we have cameras in the hall
unmanned cameras so you're sitting
during a concert and you see this camera
goes Boop and you have to really pay
attention and and play well and it's
it's it's streamed out live on the
internet once a week from the Phil emoni
and for me with my global family my
mother in London my sister in Doha my
brother in America they can all come to
the concerts live synchronous it's
actually proving to be a huge success
making the orchestra I mean even more
popular isn't it it makes us more
accessible and we try and do all sorts
of things like we offer a backstage
interviews and and we musicians
interview the guests are to do these
things called horn hangout horn hangout
so that has nothing to do with the
digital concert hall that was just a
extend its another party an extension of
your your sort of media presence I
should say yeah well it's all about it's
not an ego thing it's really literally
because when I was in Sydney and I met
all these kids who were taking part in
the YouTube Symphony Orchestra they were
so grateful for the digital concert hall
and this you can't imagine how it is for
us to sit at home in in the Amazon or
Ecuador or Taiwan and we can watch you
work and we learn so much from it and I
just thought we're in such a privileged
bubble here in Berlin we can go to the
Opera we can go to the theatre in
Germany Germany yeah in general and
these these kids use the Internet to
learn and that's what really gave me a
kick I just thought why shouldn't we why
shouldn't we get online and give a
little bit back of what what we we are
so lucky to experience another bit of
technology yeah time is the life out of
it yes you're also involved I'm one of
the 8,000 people around the world trying
out Google glass and you've got that
here we're gonna try get it to work it
will work but but um for those who don't
know what is it very basic babe please
well Google glass is basically an on a
wearable device
it's basically your phone on your face
and as you can see it's got a little
light on and I've just recorded myself
saying that to you you you speak to it
you can say you turn it on to it okay
glass take a picture smile now that was
a fabulous photo I think everyone should
get to see that yeah well I'm not so
sure okay let's find out more about this
new technology that it seems is going to
arrive in different forms from different
companies in the not so distant future
I won't quote you something you said my
friends in the horn community of being
complaining that since I've had glass
they've only seen what I see and don't
get to see me anymore I was touched no
but isn't that the problem not you
personally I can see you're a very
outgoing person but are we going to stop
communicating with each other that's a
very good question I think that's
already started to happen we're not that
we don't communicate with each other but
that this face-to-face doesn't happen I
see it in the breaks of rehearsals you
know people people still have coffee but
a lot of people just sort of look at
their phones that's the first thing they
do when they have a moment at the
airport the other day I noticed
everybody was sitting there with a phone
so what's that good for them so this is
good basically this is a wearable phone
it does still look a little bit odd and
especially here in Germany because the
they're only I think there's only one
other tester here in Germany people do
give you very odd looks what I'm using
it for is I'm just happy to try it out
in classical music I'm happy to try that
when I play the horn I tried it out in a
chamber music concert the other day I
tried it out whilst teaching and I write
all I write about it on a blog I'm happy
just that people are watching the Google
glass videos I'm making who have nothing
to do with classical music and some
somebody wrote to me said horn is so
cool I never even knew what it was until
I saw your Google glass video as we know
is not just them you know I don't to
keep mentioning the name there are other
companies and and stuff doing it but I
mean I'm just worried about this
intrusiveness I can be sitting in a
restaurant you can be sitting the other
side you could be filming me basically I
have found and I'm not just saying this
because I'm not I'm a tester and I it
doesn't mean I have to like it and I
found some things I don't like about it
but what I have found is there's nothing
I can do
secretly more secretly on this and I can
do can't do am I on my phone yeah I find
it a lot easier to do something you know
like that on my phone
firstly because you're wearing it and
you can see it and secondly you can see
there's a light on yeah and now the
lights off so secretly I can't do much
the other thing is you have to speak to
the fin so it you have to speak to it
and it
we're gonna have people wandering around
talking to them with it with a slippery
slope it it this is the thing is I
understand the privacy issues with it
but they already started it's not just
because of this they started a long time
ago and either I think there's there's
no stopping it now so everyone just has
to sort of yeah get used to it no
privacy issues here because all come
finally I think today to our our
questionnaire that we give to our guests
are you easy to fill that out you see we
don't make it easy
um I should start I think I think we'll
start with with music because you you
say memorable German music and you
mentioned bark which I think we can have
a little bit of bark now nothing I mean
so beautiful
and that's enough bat thank you because
I want to you also mention a wonderful
band called see but you also mention a
German band called Rammstein and I think
this might be a little bit different
Telos well the boys in the studio seem
to enjoy that just now it's not exactly
I wouldn't call it exactly my musical
taste but I had the privilege of meeting
one of Rammstein that the drummer
Christoph Schneider he was actually
guest on on something I was doing online
he came and cooked with us I had him a
cookery show for classical musicians and
he came in and cooked with Anna prahasta
wonderful soprano so he had the bounder
we had an operatic soprano and a
heavy-metal drummer well they're not
really heavy metal that's a long
discussion you told Oh Anna cooked a
chicken soup that kept her healthy while
she while she sings I yeah baby we're
not big cookers we're just we just get
together and then people like to tell
their secrets in the kitchen it's a
great place to do a to do a chat show
okay now ingenious German invention you
mentioned the mp3s a lot of repealer
you've also mentioned though the fan
flash and rook Garbo a little Martin
that I think anybody knows what that is
we say that in English that's the the
bottle giving back the bottles and
getting yeah what do you call it in
English fund flashing give it will you
put them deposit box deposit bottles
when you give back the bottles yes Mary
and if I say the one I particularly like
ingenious German invention this is
perhaps an in-joke so we have to explain
it says here Tegel Airport take an apple
is the lovely airport in Berlin that
works isn't it and they're going to
close it when they eventually get sure
enough out to work well we're hoping
that it's going to take a long time
before they do that I know the
government is hoping it's going to be
very quick but we love Tegel Airport
it's so close it's so small and when you
compare it to Heathrow or somewhere it's
such a dream you check in you go a few
meters and you're already at the gate
it's fantastic a favorite German word
you remember what you put I do it's a
German word do you want to pronounce it
first or shall I
I don't think I do because we tried this
before do you take me out yeah looks
moistens dude
it means as quiet as a mouse I think
it's just such a wonderful which looks
moisten still it's a lovely word don't
you think yeah and they make up words
and join them together
don't ya it's a good example that um
what else have we got good German
characteristic wanting to sit outside as
soon as the Sun comes out it's true
though maybe it's the same in every
country but I notice it here that the
minute the minute there's a little bit
of Sun even in the winter everyone's out
there wrapped up drinking their coffee
okay
and irritating German characteristic
always waiting for the light turned
green for for crossing the road I know
it's very it's a very good thing for
children to wait and if there were
children around I do agree that one
should wait always but I've stood at
traffic lights at the middle of the
night with not one car to be seen and
been told off because I've gone across
what little man was read and something
that finally something the gemsto
extremely well you put reserving some
beds with Holly but you'll be put
something else I did um they the Sun bed
seeing I'm sorry about that that was
really that was really what did I put I
think you have to organize yeah the
group Pecha linger because I can't stand
cucumbers I really can't bear cucumbers
but when I came to Germany there were
all these fantastic pickles that they
make a place called revote it's just
weird that I'm we're the people you
south of Berlin and that's where these
pickles come from and it's just
fantastic and I realize that that's one
thing than they do very well we've got
20 seconds are you staying in Germany is
this home now
it's home because I couldn't imagine
playing anywhere apart from the Berlin
Philharmonic which I just love so I'm
staying
Sarah Willis it's been a joy speaking
you today on inside Germany thanks very
much if you'd like one of Sarah's see
diesel to win one by the way there's
only couple to give away please write to
us at insite at DWD thank you for
watching thank you but beyond my guest
and playing the horn playing the the
garden hose thank you for playing the
garden home yeah I did did that and
we'll have another guest on inside Jove
at the same time next week until then
thanks watching
Oh